Overall, I would say that these colors distract from the data.
The colors shown don't appear to be chosen for any particular reason.
In fact, they're actually the default rainbow colors for the ggplot2 package for
the R programming language.
These colors are also quite bright, which strains the eyes, and above all,
each color doesn't actually convey any additional information about the data.
The labels on the left side of the bar plot are enough to
indicate which bar belongs to which type of diamond cut.
This actually makes the use of color redundant since both the labels and
the color are indicating the cut type.
You also might have thought that the legend at the right here is unnecessary.
We could simply design this visualization with the labels at the left in
the graph, decreasing the time for
the reader's eye to bounce between the legend and the main data display.
Now, I know this is a small display, but this makes sense for
larger visualizations where the eye would be scanning across an entire page.
So, when it comes to color, what should you do?